we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you know the
texas troll called in
I thought the Texas troll quit the show
he told us a couple months ago that he
was done and yet here he is again David
your last video on universal basic
income is fantastic and this is what
I've been trying to get through your
head for so long man this is what I've
been trying to tell you these oligarchs
like Mark Zuckerberg and Elon Musk etc
etc dude they love they love NAFTA they
love all these trade deals that send
jobs overseas okay because they can
benefit from it that's why you should be
supporting Trump's tariffs right now
these parents are really good they're
gonna bring back all these jobs that
left there are all these jobs that are
getting automated overseas themselves
okay these tariffs are good saying
they're gonna bring back and secure the
ones that we already have okay
tariffs are a good thing David and
progressives should support them anyway
buy it yep I disagree with the content
but I just am really confused
the Texas troll told us without any
shadow of a doubt that he was done with
the show unsubscribing and that was
going to be it and then he's back again
on today's bonus show it turns out that
the recent YouTube shooter was a vegan
activist but PETA and other animal
rights groups are not jumping up and
down to claim her we will talk about
Utah's free range parenting law which
protects parents so that kids can roam
and we will also talk about the
California driver's license program for
those in the United States illegally
undocumented immigrants which now has
surpassed 1 million drivers and it is
the subject of much ire and anger from
many on the right and we will dig into
that and much more on today's bonus show
two ways to get access to the bonus show
become a member at david pakman.com
slash membership you can also become a
patron at the $5 a month level or higher
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
which will also give you access to the
bonus show